branded is elissa quartz expose of the
advertising initiatives that target
teens and an exploration of their
consequences recently she was a guest on
the Diane Rehm Show and book TV cameras
joined her in the studio it's 50 minutes
thanks for joining us I'm Diane Rehm
each year billions of dollars are spent
by corporations to win over American
teenagers Generation Y has grown up
bombarded and defined by name products
journalist Alissa court says the buying
and selling of American teens has gone
too far she's written a book called
branded and she's here to talk about the
commercialization of youth and ways to
resist it we do invite your questions
comments join us on one eight hundred
four three three eight eight five zero
good morning Alisa thanks for joining us
good morning Diane tell me about when
you first noticed this trend of
marketing specifically toward teenagers
I was just wandering around in a mall
and I had a revelation that kids were I
had changed considerably from when I was
kid they were logos all over their
clothes they were incredibly
self-conscious their their bodies were
bared and in in new extents and when I
talked to them they spoke about feeling
like they had to wear all these branded
clothes or else just keep up with the
neighbors as it were I mean the
competition begins among the kids
themselves doesn't it aye it does I mean
I as I argue in my book it starts with
corporate strategies and marketing but
it's reflected deeply within the kids
communities yeah how far back does this
whole idea of branding
four teenagers go well kids teenagers
have been a category since the beginning
of World War two at least and the
marketing to them is not a new phenomena
but the intensity with which they've
been pursued and the way that they've
been treated as a niche especially
tweens the nine to fourteen category has
been in intensified greatly in the last
decade now is this because their
families have more money than they have
more money or is it because the
advertising campaigns have just become
so intense that they find it hard to
resist that kind of marketing well it's
a combination of factors I think parents
who are boomers and may themselves be
obsessed with Sub Zero refrigerators and
SUVs and so on and perhaps work two jobs
and had some had single families have a
lot of guilt and sometimes instead of
giving their kids attention they'll give
them a DVD player or a new pair of
sneakers so that's one part the parents
guilt absence and own interest in
branded goods the other part of this is
indeed corporate strategies it the ad
dollars spent on advertising to teens
has multiplied by 20 times in the last
decade or so well in fact you came of
age what in the eighties yes you began
noticing all the stuff surely you were
affected by it as well yeah and I mean I
write about that there is this moment I
think in every kid's life no matter what
error they they came of age and where
it's almost a rite of passage where you
recognize oh I'm being judged by how I
dress how I look what I would I wear how
affluent my family is and you know from
you I was 11 when I recognized that you
know for other kids as other ages but
you know I went to school in the fifties
High School in the fifth
these it doesn't seem to me that we so
much had brands as we had styles for
example the black and white or brown and
white oxford shoes the the cashmere
sweaters the pleated skirts I mean there
were no brand names on them but we all
sort of sought to find similarity with
our classmates and you're saying that
now they're doing that through the
branding process yeah definitely that's
the change branding also how high-end
the uniforms that kids are wearing you
know to win one another over have become
you know how much how much more
expensive the individual articles of
clothing are and also the sheer number
of clothes that kids who I interviewed
felt like they had to own a new outfit
every day so the shift is more about
quantity about luxury and about brands
and of course you've got magazines now
playing into this yeah the latest is
Teen Vogue Teen Vogue yeah tell me about
Teen Vogue oh it just launched and you
know it has the usual standbys you know
you know boyfriend boyfriends girls
talking about dealing with their weight
problems but it also has $300 shoes lots
of very expensive clothes
indeed luxury you must have they eat
yeah or just like lavish spreads you
know that that do pay homage to the
adult folk and that's a real shift I
mean even in the 80s the only ads would
be for wet-and-wild which was the
drugstore lipstick and it wouldn't be
for Chanel you know but you know um
elizy it does seem to me that parents
have to pay for such brands and don't
they put their feet down don't they say
you know this is going a little too far
gang or do they buy into this
because the kids feel so strongly about
it they buy into it because the kids
feel strongly about it but but also I
think because they themselves identify
with identify to some extent with the
need for like the need for more and more
and more of brand goods so I think it's
a two-prong thing you're saying that the
parents themselves are buying the we tal
bags they're buying the Chanel jackets
they're buying all these fancy goods so
they feel as though their kids are also
entitled yes they feel like their kids
are also entitled and they probably feel
or and some of the parents I spoke to
said they felt that it's not the worst
the worst thing so if kids are going to
act in an excessive way better that
they're you know spending too much
rather than say drinking too much I
gather in addition to Teen Vogue there's
also Elle girl is that correct right and
that's for teens what about these
so-called mega logs like Delia's well
that's to me disturbing and it's
obviously not just in the teen sector
but this kind of combination of
editorial and advertising that has
proliferated in the in the teen market
so that you'll have very sort of
poetical copy selling clothing basically
two kids who when I speak to them don't
necessarily recognize that this is an
advertisement and I think 13 year olds
and 12 year olds don't necessarily know
when they're reading a magazine or
reading an advertisement when it's at
this point so craftily when they're so
craftily mushed into one give me an
example how does that work oh I don't
know it'd be sort of prom where you know
article that's actually a lengthy sort
of advertisement kind of an actually a
catalog for the whole thing yeah and
that's what they're seeing
yeah they'd be seeing a clothing catalog
or vice versa they'd be seeing a
magazine that actually looks like a
catalog
elicit court and her new book is called
branded the buying and selling of
teenagers if you'd like to join us call
us on 136 344
it's supposed to be about self esteem
and friendship but is in fact a thinly
cloaked advertorial meant to promote
eating beef by girls and apparently it's
sponsored by the National Cattlemen's
Beef Association and the Cattlemen's
Beef board have you seen that I haven't
seen it but I've heard about it recently
also and and that is another example if
we're talking about the blurring of the
editorial and advertising lines for
young younger and younger kids that'd be
a perfect example so what they're doing
is saying that this is for young girls
but once you're drawn in they're talking
about good food choices yeah
that's right keep your weight down yeah
yeah yeah eat lots of yeah eat lots of
beef that must make parents wonder a
little bit about how their kids are
making choices yeah I think it should
the other trend that you identify is
that companies use kids themselves as
trend spotters how did they do this oh
they'll just have a call for volunteers
or they'll meet volunteers at malls or
they'll meet the parents of volunteers
who volunteers can be 13 they could be
17 and or they have a call for them
online
and then kids will basically join up and
start plumping for whatever music label
band clothier you know website they've
been why would they do that why would
kids say well sure I'll wear your brand
do do they get that brand free of charge
is that what happens yes they get it
free of charge but I think it's more
ominous than that I think it's like they
identify so heavily with the brand which
is beyond just what normal kids at this
point identify with the brand which is
I'm an old Navy girl I'm a Prada girl
I'm a Quicksilver boy they're literally
working for the brand for free of course
except they get the clothes or they get
the CDs or they get the concert tickets
or what have you so I think it's they
want to be part of they see the brand as
a star and they want to be close to this
star it's like a celebrity well and
speaking of stars of course we've seen
all kinds of product placements in
movies and and on television that kind
of thing
yeah and ever more so and partially
because adolescents don't watch as much
television actually as they they may be
playing more video game video game and
the television they do watch they are
suspicious of conventional
advertisements so the new trend is to
put a Nokia in the hand of a character
on a reality show to name one example or
a Coca Cola moment to have these moments
of wear which are basically branded
moments instead of actually being
advertisements branded moments within
the television show or in the video game
they there's video games based on
skittles the candy tell me about that
it's called darkened sky and the entire
premise of the game is to collect
skittles
we're fairy I think it's a fairy
princess and a dark land is trying to
you know the skittles give her magical
powers
there's also games involving you know
Big Macs and and cellphones and jeeps
and the Jeep's are did their displaced
they're sort of you know covertly so
that a kid would be playing over and
over again I keep seeing Jeep Jeep Jeep
and I think that's going to be the wave
of the future actually that kind of
placement at video games listen just for
our listeners sake you him on a gray
cardigan beneath it you have on an off
white t-shirt
are those branded items that you buy and
think about very carefully um yes I got
these on sale of I did get them from a
brand new zing ELISA course her book is
called branded the buying and selling of
teenagers when we come back we'll take
your comments questions
join us on one eight hundred four three
three eight eight five zero that's a
very interesting trend really very
interesting trend ah yes
using teens in the commercials
themselves you know targeting is it Robo
Chi R a bocce a robotic toy animal do
you know anything about this
for young children under 12
all day now that's interesting here's a
woman who's taking issue with me okay
yeah
and welcome back Elissa Court is with me
if you just joined us we're talking
about the ongoing phenomenon and indeed
many would say as Elissa does that it's
a growing phenomenon of branding
marketing specifically to teenagers
who've got lots of expendable cash to
spend they're looking for particular
brands because those brands are being
marketed specifically to them here is an
email from Jean who says she loves the
show but she wants to disagree with me
on brands for teens in the 1950s you and
I are about the same age he says and I
still recall the brand's de rigueur from
high school in college Spaulding saddle
shoes Adlard triple cuff shots
socks Janssen cashmere sweaters
honest to goodness I don't remember a
single brand name all I remember is the
style of what we wear and we'd all copy
each other is that part of what's going
on here copying each other - uh yeah
definitely and I think as we were
discussing earlier part of the viral
marketing where viral means kids
communicating to other kids hey this is
a great new band you know online at the
behest of a music label for instance
that kind of viral marketing can only
happen because kids do copy each other
and if one kid says hey this band is
great huh you know and that that's
that's it's a natural process that
marketers have now taken
advantage of what about within the
schools themselves you've got a growing
number of schools where for example coke
has bought a concession or Pepsi has
bought a concession so you see that
branding going on even within the
so-called safety the schools oh yeah I
find that quite awful there's a
rust-oleum gym in Illinois named after
the paint company so if you know kids
they're playing field
you know hockey or kickball in a paint
company gym ten percent of all schools
have soda pouring contracts as you just
described which means that Pepsi or coke
or some other bottlers has is the only
company allowed to sell their sodas in
the school but it let's say isn't I mean
this sounds as though it's a flowing
river a mass ocean that cannot be
stopped why are you calling such
attention to it I think that there
should be greater restrictions on
corporate marketing to kids like what
for one thing I think they need to
disclose their mark that their efforts
are in fact marketing efforts and that's
not happening consistently to be very
clear about those so-called mega logs
for example not just the magg logs
there's companies that go into schools
and collect information personal
information about kids within school
hours and then sell that information to
cosmetics companies and credit card
companies and are you saying that these
schools are being reimbursed for getting
that information well actually in one
instance a company pretended to be a
non-profit an educational nonprofit that
was just a court case and pretended to
be an educational nonprofit collected
the information and sold it to companies
where did that occur in New York in New
York State and I feel like
and many other instances of that sort of
you know borderline activity and I feel
like full disclosure disclosure of
marketing techniques you know publicly
so parents can know how their kids may
be being marketed to and just sort of a
guy a set of guidelines really first do
you think that would change anything do
you think kids would perhaps by fewer
branded products if they knew the extent
to which they are being manipulated if
you will I I think perhaps that but I
also think if kids and parents spent
some time per week looking at looking at
how advertisements are working upon them
looking at the videogames looking at MTV
sort of imagery and discussing it you
know engaging in media criticism
basically together I think that would go
a long way also at least perhaps not to
get kids to stop stop the tide of hyper
consumerism but to stop it from entering
their souls mm-hmm you also say that
marketers are pushing adult products on
adolescence give me an example well you
know a example from my book was you know
I went to a bar mitzvah promotional
event and a promotional event for for
party planners so there's like a party
planner I'd say promotional events so
there's hundreds of you know people
magicians you know the usual kind of
party party stuff but there was also a
number of people putting on tattoos it
said sexy you know an extremely kind of
adult themed entertainments gyrating you
know gyrating dancers and the like and I
felt like that was one example among
many of the adult offical of kids what
about these so-called alcopops oh that's
a tricky issue because
the alcohol distillers would never cop
to selling to kids under 21 but there's
something distinctly adolescent about
these alcopops that they've been
spending millions and millions in 2002
to sell they're called things like
Bodines twisted tea they look like
Snapple they're fruity but they're
alcohol but they can't be sold over the
counter to kids they can only be sold to
adults but you're saying the packaging
the presentation makes it look
attractive and available to kids exactly
exactly so there's a lot of line
crossing going on that's right and I
think that that's one thing that I've
tried to highlight in my book it's a
sort of Twilight territory here it's
often alright we've got lots of colors
so let's open the phones now if you'll
put those headphones on 1-800 four three
three eight eight five zero let's go
first to Alexandria Virginia good
morning Lori good morning I just wanted
to make a quick comment sure that it's
not just the brand names it's also the
accumulation of stuff I mean from the
time these kids are infants if they get
a happy meal in McDonald's they get a
toy if they go to a birthday party they
get a party favor bag everything
nowadays is connected to some piece of
merchandise and as hard as I have tried
as a parent and I have a nine year old
and a 12 year old now the amount of
stuff that they accumulate from other
sources and the marketing that goes on
is unbelievable and I often joke that if
we ever had a nuclear war the one thing
that would survive are plastic and
McDonald's toys oh dear I mean it is
just it is just a phenomenal the amount
of marketing for more and more stuff
let's say that begins as Laurie is
saying really quite young oh yeah it's a
cradle-to-grave marketing at this point
almost before kids can talk there
already being targeted well you know
parents him and have peel bevel here but
they're not helpless no I mean uh as I
was saying you can lift the try to lift
the curtain with your kids sure all
right to Cleveland Ohio
good morning David you're on the air
good morning Bonnie I have three kids my
oldest is an 11 year old girl and I
absolutely agree that marketing towards
kids has really become a challenge for
parents I think there's always been
communication between businesses and
kids and it's changed over the last
generation or two just the way all other
communication has changed there's a lot
more of it it's it's a big ewis I mean
it's all over the place but our own
behavior is really the driver the first
words out of your guests mouth for well
the thought occurred to me while I was
walking through the mall well that was a
choice you know you can recreational
shopping and recreational consumption is
a byproduct of you know this fabulous
wealth that we have is our as in our
country but it's all it's not an
obligation there's plenty of other
things that you can do with your kids
and teach your kids that aren't
consumption focused every day at school
my kids have the choice to buy a candy
bar I choose as their parent not to let
them it's not that they're they can't
have candy or other treats but in order
to teach them how to handle that
decision-making about money responsibly
you got to introduce some restrictions
when their kids and gradually offer them
more freedom as they demonstrate the
ability to make smart decisions Melissa
I mean it sounds like you're a really
good parent I mean I don't think that
many parents can have the time or the
wherewithal though to make sure that
their kids are having the proper
restrictions and freedoms at the right
points in their lives David do you think
you're unusual um you know I'm 40 years
old and I have a zero credit card debt
okay I have friends who were people who
I respect who have very similar values
to me who have significant credit card
debt the difference is how we were
taught specifically taught how to use it
and it's a skill set that I agree a
generation or two ago you probably
didn't need and it
probably wasn't as important you know if
you did need it just like you know the
communication skills that we need today
are different should I think that that
we it's unrealistic for us as parents to
say well society has to fix this the
school for the marketing know we we we
have to do it as parent he's very
passionate yeah a very passionate and
he's right I mean to a large extent that
it does come down to the relationship
between the parent and child the
instruction the child receives not only
through what the parent says but how the
parent uses money wouldn't you agree
oh definitely but the fastest growing
group filing for bankruptcy are those
under 25 I was astonished to read that
in your book how can that be
elissa partially I think because credit
card companies are targeting kids at
college-age kids and younger and and
also as the last two collars have said
this intense accumulation drive to
accumulation drive to market to kids has
changed the the skill set that kids need
and they don't necessarily have that
skill set they don't know how to
navigate it but again do credit cards
given to kids who are 18 and above don't
they have to be co-signed by a parent or
can they simply be issued I think there
are definitely issues with that although
a number of credit card companies have
come out with cards like the Visa bucks
card cards that are aimed at kids you
know and something like 12% of kids have
their own credit cards extraordinary add
25 before the hour you're listening to
the Diane Rehm Show and we'll go to
Royal Oak Michigan good morning Walt
oh thanks Diane sure I have a comment
and
question s and I would say that maybe
the young people are no more vulnerable
than older people and you know style
based clothes or other items you know
overcoming the significance of content
do you know that you know we who are a
little bit older might you know think
that a you know a dark suit and a blue
tie might lend more credibility to an
argument and you know somebody with
purple hair and a bone in their nose you
know you know somebody in a lab coat
make being able to make a subject you
know torture somebody in a box because
you know it's okay you know figure of
authority but now the same thing you
know you know using style to convince
young people that they're red well
actually they're being more homogenized
into the you know clothes culture that
sort of thing you know it's kind of the
same mechanism but my question is what
is this you know as far as globalizing
this to the whole world you know is this
really the face that we want to present
for you know being the main thing that
people overseas see of America and it is
being spread across the world isn't it
yeah definitely
I mean it's most intense in the US but
other countries are following in our
wake in on there's some trends however
in this very vein that had begun in
Europe that in London for example or
Paris where some of these fashion trends
begin the acquisition or the desire for
acquisition may get to the US but the
fashion trend itself the marketing
begins in Europe yeah I just heard about
some London PR firm that was tattooing
logos on people's foreheads uh you know
not permanent logo
but so that would be a form of
advertising logo young phorid yeah yeah
so obviously it's all over the world at
this point um you know you also write
something of an inversion the youth cult
explosion of 30 years ago and how this
is affecting kids yeah
the youth cult was definitely sort of a
desirable youth was a desirable identity
in the 60s and now at this point kids
want to look like adults the toy
manufacturers of America I used to sell
to toys to 14 and under now it's 10 and
under so when a kid is 10 or 11 they're
already aspiring to be an adolescent or
adult character on Sex in the City so
it's a real reversal and now the adults
are trying to look more like kids as
well okay
yeah so I as I write my book you know
they meet in between
mom mom will try to look like her
daughter and a daughter will try to look
like her mom that's too bad yeah it's an
odd thing do you think girls are more
affected than boys probably by that yes
I mean as there is a number of things in
which boys are I feel that marketing and
branding and commodity culture has
affected boys their body images for one
thing you know as I was saying video
games extreme sports it's on other areas
you know of course there is that rather
blatant example of the young man the
high school basketball player who
decided to take two jerseys that were
offered to him by a particular store as
long as the store was able to take
photographs of him and he's now been
suspended by a couple of games his
mother took out a loan to buy him
a Hummer a hundred and fifty thousand
dollar loan to buy her son a Hummer
based on his future earnings so these
t-shirts at three hundred and eighty
five dollars or whatever seem like small
change but I mean as kind of branding
goes on all the time and athletes are
definitely up there as far as carrying
that brand we'll take just a short break
here when we come back we've got tons of
calls we'll try to get to all of them
before the top of the hour stay with us
oh here's a caller hello this is the
parent I was gonna get to this yeah this
is NPR National Public Radio car
companies
good and he looks for sales how do you
talk to your kids so we've got to get to
these cones so yeah well one person
you've met any of the people behind
these marketing ploys and what they have
said to you and I think that's a good
question we've got one on the line who
says he produces television commercials
so we'll go to him next just know that
at the end I have to run across the hall
very quickly so I'll have to at the end
did this show all I have to run across
the hall very quickly okay okay all
right I don't want you to think I'm rude
okay
all right and our next caller is in
Miami Florida
good morning Miriam you're on the air hi
there I'm a person that considers myself
to be part of the problem in a way
because I'm in the media I'm a
commercial producer so we are constantly
being given a lot of information by
advertising agencies as to the latest
brands what kids wants all the marketing
statistics that support the growth of
the buying power of kids but to me it's
not so much the buying power that as it
is the manipulative power because we're
constantly being told that kids feel
they need this they need that and
therefore they're manipulating their
parents into buying these things so
which leads me to my other comment and
you touched upon it earlier when it when
you said it would be nice if the parents
took time to speak to their children and
really analyze the media that they're
that they're seeing but of course I
would imply that parents really aardman
spend time analyzing surance and what
I'm finding literally because all our
focus groups tell us is that parents
spend less and less time they pretty
much give in and say hey you want to
look like Britney Spears and you want
these things go for it get it and to me
that is just really noticeable in this
generation above anything else so it's
it's I've seen the growth of it through
my career but this generation is is
extremely susceptible to this which
tells me that this generation of parents
is not spending the time to really talk
to their child and also tell the child
hey you're okay you don't need to have
these things well let me reassure you
Miriam we've gotten lots of emails from
parents who are saying this is how I'm
handling it this is how I'm dealing with
the problem so clearly there are a lot
of people out there who are trying to
watch your advice as to the best way
Alyssa that parents should deal with
this question well as I said discuss
media to the commercial media with them
talk about their feelings about it
parents should be doing this with their
kids another
practice is a the counter ad where kids
learn how to create an ad an anti a dad
or that's a way of just learning media
literacy from inside like oh this is how
an advertisement or a billboard works by
making one that's been pretty effective
instead of the anti-smoking campaigns
where kids have made kind of
anti-smoking advertisements I see now
what about kids who totally resist this
kind of branding did you talk with him
as well yeah I talked with dozens of
them actually and I found them pretty
moving actually there's a number of
different ways in which kids are
expressing those impulses how some of
them are through kind of typical
activism you know rallies some of them
from work sort of new imaginative forms
of activism like subvert izing which is
an example of subvert izing would be to
change the Nike presto sign into not
impressed oh and sort of it's sort of
the equivalent of drawing the mustache
on the ad for you know an ad for a
shampoo ad um on the models face do they
try to draw attention for example to
their own non branded clothes yeah they
do
definitely they'll when you ask them
where they shop they'll say Goodwill
Salvation Army very proudly so you know
in a way that just fits in with a lot of
as I write in my book kind of maverick
identities the kids have always had yeah
kids have always had and I was just
thinking of my husband who went to
friend seminary in New York back in the
40s and they were a lot of quite wealthy
young people there but he and his group
of male friends all decided that they
were gonna wear the oldest clothes they
had to school every single day and
before long the entire class had done
the same thing meaning his family didn't
have any money but he was going to
school
the lot of kids who did who could afford
that sort of thing
so it does seem to me the parents can
have a certain amount of the impact but
the kids themselves can do a lot more
yeah kids can do a lot more in a certain
way I mean they can certainly talk to
one another which I was moved by also
just the ways that kids were
communicating with one another I went to
this one school in Maine and went to
it's kind of anti-corporate school play
where kids had put on a play that was
criticizing advertising and the way
those school within the school huh and I
talked to them and it seemed like they
had conversations frequently about body
image about the way they were being sort
of marketed to so aggressively and how
they were negotiating it and those
conversations with one another had
really helped them 1-800 four three
three eight eight five zero two Holly in
Salt Lake City good morning to you good
morning Dianne and Alyssa thank you for
taking my call I find this topic so
intriguing and quickly just a couple of
quick comments I actually write a column
for the Salt Lake Tribune here the
morning newspaper and have used my own
two children this fourteen and a half
and twelve year old as labrat so
frequently this topic I've touched on
this a little bit but two quick things
if I may one thing that I found very
interesting about three years ago my
husband and I were divorced and boy if
that didn't sort of swing me around
quickly to realizing that I didn't have
a big choice about buying my children
every brand doing everything else so you
know I think we've talked a lot about
that in the last couple of years without
getting obsessive about money I've been
very clear with them we've talked a lot
about needs versus wants and that kind
of thing are you yeah and the other
thing is my own daughter she's a
freshman in high school and she and her
and her close circle of friends three or
four girls have worked very hard in the
last I'd say six months or so kind of
doing an anti branding
after which ties me to what you were
talking about a couple of minutes ago
what teenagers are doing maybe to fight
all of this
they almost exclusively and we do buy it
by brands periodically but they almost
exclusively shop at flea markets and
vintage stores and goodwill and they do
a lot to sort of develop this little
trend in their in their group of friends
of you know buying the old stuff they're
going to establish their own non
branding brand yeah it's you know when
she comes home from a little shopping
spree we talk about it and we just feel
so much better that you know she bought
five outfits for fifty dollars rather
than you know one outfit for $100
exactly and probably lots of young
people out there are doing exactly that
at ten minutes before the hour you're
listening to the Diane Rehm Show and
thanks so much for calling let's go now
to Papa Michigan
good morning Suzanne good morning I
guess I have a couple of comments first
everybody is touching on so many
wonderful points my husband and I were
married very young and our children are
21 and 19 so we went through the tween
thing but I look back in the 70s and we
were growing up and we didn't have 25 or
50 channels of television we didn't have
10 magazines that were focused on us
like the kids do now we didn't have
Nintendo and a lot of the other things
that they do have and we had in comic
books I think that was about it
yeah you know and and like one of the
last caller just stated it was a joke at
our house it was called a we need
because we had to decide if it was a
want or a need and they would save money
or they would put things on layaway
which nobody does anymore because stores
don't want you to do that you either put
it on credit or you know you wait until
you save the money sure I haven't heard
that word layaway and so long Alyssa
yeah I haven't either yeah yeah no and
our son now lives in New York City he
does go to the vintage stores which I've
been told you don't call goodwill
goodwill anymore it's a vintage store
our daughters in college and yeah she
does buy some brand name stuff but she
also goes to the vintage stores and she
really likes some and both of them do
he's been doing that since he was 14
that's terrific
well good for you Suzanne I'm sure
you've given some other people some
great ideas thanks for calling let's go
to Cleveland Ohio hi Ryan
you're on the air sure I'm in that
bracket of born I was born in 79 and my
parents didn't really let me or my
brother's get exposed too much dating
the mass stuff and none of us really are
have any care about any brand names my
brothers are both into the thrift store
thing but my point was is that uh seems
like there's a fear of Brand X that's
out today that nobody really they don't
want to buy something that's unknown
like when I go to a I want to sandwich I
don't go to Subway I would go to a sub
shop you know down the street that's not
a major change but a lot of people don't
want to do that because they don't want
to they've seen all the commercials
you've tried the other brand but this is
the name-brand this is the one you want
and it's pretty much what I was wanting
to say good I'm glad you said it but do
you think in the young people to whom
you talked that there is a growing
segment of that population that's really
deliberately seeking out non brand names
or going to a sub shop instead of a
subway I hope so I really I find it
heartening these calls especially the
last one I should say all right in to
Dover New Hampshire hi Michele hi I have
three kids my oldest of which is five
and already I'm having trouble finding
age appropriate clothing for my daughter
everything has sexy sexy across the top
or their their halters or they don't
come down far enough and it's really
frustrating you know I
expect that at the more trendy stores
but you know the regular department
stores we have that problem now and the
other thing that we're doing to try to
you know just calm things down is my
daughter has a birthday party this
Sunday and instead of gifts she was
given the opportunity to invite all her
class or no guests and she chose to
invite all her class good for her yeah
pretty smart kid yeah I like it but your
point about finding age-appropriate
clothes for five-year-olds is really a
good one I've walked through department
stores and clothing shops unless you go
to a true children's clothing shop you
see and exactly as you said all of these
sort of you know sexy provocative
clothes for a five-year-old girl which I
just find really strange
have you seen that as well Alyssa yeah I
mean certainly especially Abercrombie
and Fitch the thongs that are aimed at
the preteen set and they have I believe
eye candy and wink wink on them and you
know we're like I remember the porn star
t-shirts that were popular mmm maybe two
or three years ago that were also for
preteens and I guess I don't want to
make an argument that's that adolescents
should not be interested in sex not
sexually active I don't agree with that
at all but I think to think of
themselves as sex objects when they're
12 is troubling to say the least and
that is what clothing can do after all
all right we've got time for one last
caller let's go to Miami Florida and to
Bruce good morning to you hi good
morning - quick question very quick
please quick one one is this whole
conversation is part of the reason why
I'm a big advocate of school uniform
programs and secondly I think a lot of
the topics that you've touched on today
are really part of a diabolical if I'll
use that word marketing
that's tied in to why people are so
against the whole globalization idea
I'll leave those two within taking our
sponsor all right thanks for calling
what do you think about school uniforms
Alisa I guess I don't think it addresses
the problem I can see the use of having
it having school uniforms within school
but in a sense I think it creates a
forbidden fruit of brands and it's not
enough I mean it's not helping kids work
through their desires that whole need
and wanting problem what about his point
that really it's all connected to this
larger problem of globalization and
marketing to different countries and
translating our standards of ethics and
our standards of what's beauty and
what's effective to other cultures that
in some ways have come to resent us I
think indeed and I mean you know
Americana itself is something of a brand
and that's the last word from Alissa
court her new book is called branded the
buying and selling of teenagers thanks
so much for doing this work and for
being here oh you're so welcome
and thanks to our listeners I'm Diane
Rehm the Diane Rehm show is produced by
Sandra Pinkert Elisabeth Terry a net
Alisa cord is author of branded the
buying and selling of teenagers it's
published by Perseus on the web at
Perseus publishing com